[Music]
this week's 48 hours investigates the
kidnapping and murder of a tech
executive turned cannabis entrepreneur
his name is tushar altre he was attacked
he was kidnapped in his multi-million
dollar california home this was back in
october of 2019
hours later found dead on his cannabis
farm just 14 miles away from his home as
48 hours correspondent tracy smith shows
us some grainy surveillance video played
a key role in this case
he loved the ocean he just loved surfing
when tushar atrey wasn't surfing the
waves just steps from his beach house in
santa cruz he was working on producing
medicinal cannabis products says his
girlfriend and business partner rachel
emerly we've gotten it to the point
where we felt like this is the product
we were trying to make rachel says she
learned tushar had been kidnapped when
investigators called her on october 1st
2019.
i was trying to piece together what this
all meant over the phone what do you
mean he didn't seem like he was in
danger the crime scene provided few
clues but several people in tushar's
house heard the intruders says mary
fulginiti a former federal prosecutor
and 48 hours consultant one witness
hears three different voices the unknown
voices were heard asking about a safe
tushar kept in his bedroom that
investigators say contained 80 thousand
dollars in cash put your hands behind
your back where is the safe and what's
the combination nearly six hours later
at his cannabis farm sheriff's deputies
discovered the bloody body of tushar
atre
former california police chief and 48
hours consultant steve circone his hands
were handcuffed in the back with flex
ties an apparent gunshot wound to the
back of the head he'd been stabbed
multiple times this was a whodunit from
the start investigators hoped
surveillance footage showing three
shadowy figures approaching tushar's
home would help them crack the case
as you'll see here mr artre breaks from
the driveway and he runs and he's
pursued by one of the suspects
he tackles him right here and as you can
see there's a struggle if this was a
robbery why chase him tackle him and
take him away if this is truly just a
simple robbery once he runs away you let
him go this is about more than just
money it's definitely about more than
money where are you two sir what
happened
and tracy smith
and tracy smith joins us now what a
story tracy from that beautiful home to
the bloody crime scene and that grainy
surveillance video it makes me wonder if
authorities had video like that were
they able to identify suspects quickly
well actually no because even though you
could see what happened in that video it
was tough to see who did it because it
was so grainy so investigators spent
months analyzing digital data looking at
more surveillance video until finally
they were able to piece together what
happened
go ahead
well do investigators think it was
related to the cannabis business because
you've got the safe in the house but
then they take them to the farm
right you know
we were told that tushar did everything
by the book but some investors did
accuse him of dealing in the black
market so this was something else that
investigators had to look into
just a really grisly story and a
fascinating mystery looking forward to
it tracy smith thank you very much and
you can see tracy's report who shot the
tech exec on 48 hours tomorrow night at
10 9 central right here on cbs and on
our streaming service paramount plus
we'll be right back